what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
so with the current run of Batman
focusing so heavily on Bane that is to
say what's being written right now with
I am suicide what I want to do here is I
want I went over the DC rebirth origin
of Bane and what I mean is basically the
origin of Bane that's being used for DC
rebirth now the reason why I really
chose to start with Bane is because he's
the quintessential example of everything
that's going on with regards to DC
rebirth now for those of you guys who
are new to DC Comics or to comic books
as a whole
DC rebirth isn't really a reboot so much
as it's designed to take what worked
with the pre new 52 and roll that in to
the new 52 the issue with this was that
when the Batman series was launched in
2011 because Batman was so popular it
didn't make any sense to wipe the slate
clean the issue with this was that DC
was just kind of walking the line they
were going back and forth they wouldn't
confirm the Batman was rebooted but they
wouldn't say that he wasn't rebooted
what they did is they said everything
that happened from the time that
Batman's publications first began
following the events of crisis on
Infinite Earths up until the start of
the new 52 all happened within a you
know five-year window and so we as the
reader were expected to believe that he
had trained six Robins in five years
that he learned of Damian Wayne's
existence in five years which didn't
make any sense because Damian Wayne was
10 there were a lot of things that
didn't seem to add up but DC wouldn't
really give a straight answer and all
they said was well you know maybe it
happened maybe it didn't you know no
story is is true until it's basically
confirmed to exist in DC by way of
injection and a comics and so when the
new 52 first launched for Batman it was
like Bane didn't exist but then suddenly
Bane popped up in Batman Batman and
Robin eternal from Scott Snyder and now
Bane was there and so with that end ever
nine sort of touching on Bane's origin a
little bit it really ties into the idea
that Bane his origin as it exists in DC
rebirth is effectively the original
origin now this story came out of
something called the vengeance of Bane
which was written by Chuck Dixon and it
was actually a prelude to the nightfall
story arc really the first major role
that Bane would ever play in DC Comics
and what this does is this basically
just gives us the quintessential story
in the sense that it tells us that
Bane's father was a revolutionary that
he tried to rise up against the
government and tried to topple that
government and because of the fact that
you know the father perished in the
incident it resulted in the
basically serving out the sentence of
his father now because of the fact that
this nation existed in a very archaic
structure what it said was that only the
son of a criminal could serve out the
sentence not a daughter but because of
the fact that Bane was born a boy and
because he was a baby not only was he
imprisoned his mother was imprisoned as
well so she could take care of babe now
a lot of this story is told to us from
the perspective of a guy named zombie
and zombie was basically there when Bane
first showed up he was there when his
mom showed up and he was watching from
the shadows Wow you know Bane's mother
lived in the infirmary to raise her
child and watched as she effectively
began to give up on life that's really
just what happened to her you know she
really just sort of gave up did she she
really couldn't handle life in prison
and so because of this Bane was very
much left to his own devices in terms of
exploring the prison in terms of running
around now as a child
Dean was very much like any child he was
curious he was adventurous but he you
know being in this sort of prison
environment led to some very dark things
and that sense that he learned about the
corruption that went on behind the
scenes in prison he learned about how
prisoners were bribing guards for the
purpose of turning a blind eye while
those same prisoners killed somebody
else he was forced to watch all these
different things unfold and so the time
eventually came whereby he had witnessed
his mother's death where she had
basically just sort of given up in her
entirety and passed on and instead of
receiving an adequate burial instead of
receiving an appropriate burial instead
she was quite literally just thrown over
a cliff unceremoniously to be consumed
by sharks and that's how harsh this
place was there was really no concern
from the warden on the prisoners
themselves and in fact the warden would
just allow the prisoners to kill one
another because this prison itself was
designed to keep the inmates in they
didn't really care what they did to each
other as far as the warden was concerned
as long as they weren't escaping it
didn't really matter as long as they
didn't come after him or initiate a riot
or something like that and so in
response Bane was basically sent out to
his cell by himself being old enough
with no one to really take care of him
and had to make his own way now
initially one of the guys simply shows
that you know this this guy worker shows
up and basically starts to intimidate
Bane and he basically says you know hey
you're gonna start working for me now
there's no indication from Chuck Dixon
that Puerco intended to use Bane for
illicit purposes but it does indicate
that poor crow intended to use Bane for
the purpose of thievery because he was
so small he could slip past prison
guards for the purpose of turning Bane
into a murderer to carry out assassins
against other prisoners but what happens
is a guy named Trog basically steps up
and says no you're not gonna use this
kid and we're pero initially tries to
fight tog off Trog just tumbles in and
his entirety now hobbs also a very very
important character here once we get to
the conclusion of this because he will
basically be part of names inner circle
but what happens is in the midst of this
conflict the Bane is knocked off second
or third level of the prison and as a
result falls into the ground below and
goes unconscious now during this time
Chuck Dixon isn't really clear here he
kind of walks the line between like the
hallucination or between like you know a
future appearance of Bane or something
like that but basically the child
version of Bane has a experience where
he talks to his older self and his older
self says I'm the person you will become
but in order for you to get to where I'm
at to where you don't have to worry
about people who are gonna be coming
after you you have to learn to conquer
fear you have to learn to get past this
now this is extremely important when it
comes to the character of a not because
of the fact that he you know broke
Batman's back but because this is really
Chuck Dixon telling us you know Bane's
journey to become the villain that we
know today was almost identical to
Batman and this since a Batman witnessed
his parents murdered he was immersed in
fear but he had to overcome that fear
through training through hard work
through expanding his own intelligence
Dave's journey is almost identical it's
it's crazy how close they are in
similarity now of course they didn't
have the wealth that Batman did and he
didn't have the freedom that Bruce Wayne
had which means that he wasn't able to
travel around the world and experience
all kinds of all kinds of training but
in truth he didn't need to and the
reason why is because the training
effectively caved to him what happens is
he wakes up about 31 days after his
after falling into a coma and when he
arrives he's basically turned into a
feral animal he's basically killing off
anybody that could possibly threaten him
and he quite literally returns to work
oh and kills him stabs him to death not
only that he starts doing that to a host
of different prisoners those who seem to
want to take advantage of them or the
very least those he simply doesn't like
and this is really just vane carving out
a niche for himself letting people know
that he can't be messed with and so
where the warden initially says hey okay
we got to put him in isolation Bane
goads him Bane says hey look I talked to
my mother last night you know I talked
my mother while I was in a coma and she
said that hel is stoking fires just for
you basically meaning that there's a
special place in hell for the warden and
as a result he lashes out at bay now the
where the warden reacts this way and in
fact what zombie tells us is bane that
was very sadistic Bane's very cruel but
there's also something terrifying about
a teenage boy going on a murderous
rampage being feared by some of the most
feared people in the world who were all
in this in this prison so because of the
fact that Bane had such an impact on the
warden because he was able to shake the
ward in his boots the result is that
Trog and other prisoners overheard Bane
now this is where Batman number 9 right
now from DC rebirth comes into play he's
the only teases it you know they don't
really go end up there and this was
basically DC saying hey this vengeance
of Bane storyline is still his official
origin this is still the origin that
we're using from the time that he was
thrown in prison up until the time that
he was thrown into a solitary
confinement up until the time that he
emerged around ten years passed for ten
years he went from being a boy growing
into a man but the entire time of this
happened he basically had to fend for
his life the ocean waters would come in
during high tide they were threatened to
drown him you know he had to basically
catch her fish who were coming in
through the prison bars when the when
the high tide came in he would capture
them and then he would Ethan it was
quite literally you know survival of the
fittest in a four by four cell and so he
was doing the best he could but the
result was that he had basically
hardened himself in the extreme when it
came to surviving when it came to making
his way in addition to this he honed his
mind he sharpened his mind in the sense
that he would imagine himself traveling
off to different places and fighting
against incredible foes and so by the
time he emerged from solitary
confinement they knew no fear he was
afraid of nothing all he wanted to do
was get out you know get out of this
prison and he want to solidify his
legacy now we don't really learn much
about Gotham initially instead what
happens is he comes out and the people
the other prisoners in prison they view
him as a hero they view him as a legend
because he embarrassed the ward the ward
was hoping he would drown where he would
starve to death or he would you know die
a verse or something the warden was
hoping that he would end up perishing in
the south but instead you know Bane just
kept himself alive by sheer force of
will and the result is of the other
prisoners look up to him now during this
time that once he actually gets out he
comes across a guy named bird now bird
is from Gotham City and bird is the guy
who tells Bane hey look you know I come
from a place named Gotham you know it's
it's the reason why I'm sitting here you
know because of the some people I was
mixed up in some affairs these different
things like that
Bane doesn't initially give it a whole
lot of thought
you know off the top of his head but
there are a few things you know that
that bird throws out in terms of you
know being able to access a means to
solidify his legacy more or less but the
main goal of bane after his release is
to basically exemplify himself to be a
model prisoner to be able to access the
kind of things that he should be able to
access in terms of books but to also
sharpen his mind in terms of
intelligence now this is one of the big
differences between Bane and the comics
and like Tom Hardy's Bane and the Dark
Knight Returns one of the reasons why a
lot of fans got so angry with Tom
Hardy's Bane is that while Tom Hardy is
an amazing actor and they had one hell
of a fight scene between Bane and Batman
at the end of the movie he was basically
a henchman for Talia al Ghul and the
comics Bane's nobodies henchmen he is
one of the smartest people when it comes
to a lot of things you know that that's
what zombie tells us is that they began
to access books on science you know on
classic literature on giving himself a
classic education learning as much as he
possibly could about becoming as
intelligent as possible this is by the
time he emerged from prison not only was
he wildly smart he was also honed in
terms of his physical abilities strength
his you know athleticism his agility so
on and so forth in terms of his fighting
because of the fact that the prison was
home to so many people from so many
different places across the world Bane
quite literally just engaged in a Fight
Club with these guys and so he was
learning all different forms of fighting
from all over the world so where Batman
quite literally traveled the world to
learn these different styles of fighting
the prisoners were already there for me
all he had to do was just fight them in
order to learn how you know what their
styles are in order to learn you know
how they move or move around accordingly
now the other half of this is that
because he's been so successful here
because he's really like the top dog in
the realm of this prison you know he
tells Bert
tell me about Gotham City because at
this point he's very intrigued in terms
of what he can do and this is when bird
says well no one really runs Gotham you
know no one runs this show obvious you
know if you're a criminal
it's a kid in a candy store but when
when night falls Batman runs the show
Batman comes out now Bane immediately is
you know intrigued by Batman the reason
why is because it's one guy who controls
a city through fear and so Bane's Bane's
motivation is that if it's one man who's
this capable if it's one man that's able
to dominate a city with fear like this
then he wants to know who that man is he
wants to find him and he wants to
basically defeat him and
proved himself to be the absolute
strongest and from there probably take
over Gotham and so what vein does if she
just starts going through you know he
starts getting irritated to the fact but
he's stuck in this prison and he can't
leave
and so his rage gives way to killing
prisoners which in turn allows a warden
to basically hand him over to scientists
now the reason why the warden does this
it's too full the first is hat is that
these scientists are engaging in a
procedure that will you know it was
designed for some sort of military
application and a Super Soldier Serum or
something akin to that but they use a
substance called venom which basically
enhances the strength of the people who
take it the problem with this is that
those individuals who has been tested on
so far have all died and so for the
warden Bane will be out of his hair
either way either the experiment will be
successful in Bane will you know go off
and leave the prison doing whatever it
is the military wants to do or Bane will
die in the procedure but either way the
woodies life will be free of this curse
that he's been dealing with for decades
and so what happens is Bane is exposed
to the procedure and he survives the
initial injections which no one else had
done and because he survives that they
begin the process of placing implants in
his brain that allows them to inject
venom directly into his mind and so
because of this Bane is considered to be
the quintessential survivor that one guy
that could basically go forward as an
agent of whoever it is that has
contracted these these doctors and so
from here we also have zombie who
basically swiped a sample of the venom
Sherman the reason why he did this is
because he was an expert in
pharmaceuticals which means that he
could basically go through the
ingredients that this thing is you know
the make up this thing and then in turn
take them you know duplicate them and
create his own version of venom and so
what Bane does is he says okay fine if
you can do that then here's the plan I'm
going to will my vitals to go down to
the point where the machines can read
them and believe that I'm dead and when
that happens they're going to dispose of
my body by throwing it over a cliff just
like they do with my mother and then I'm
going to come back we're going to you
know get rid of the ward we're gonna
kill him off you know this is gonna be
my de facto base you know where he's
gonna be in control here kind of like a
king there's not currently sitting at
the throne and then he's going to head
to Gotham and he's gonna face off
against Batman and that's exactly what
he does you know once they throw his
body over he immediately takes out the
Sharks just because of his you know his
strength you know he travels and
effectively takes over is able to
converse with Hugo Strange and in doing
so is able to secure some arms and
armament and then eventually bring a
helicopter
to the prison grab Trog along with a
couple other guys and then take off of
course they killed a warden in the
process just for the heck of it but the
result here is that what's that once
they get to Gotham they have the bird
manufacturer a few false identities a
Trog begins work on his electronics
expertise as well as zombie you know
duplicating the serum and the result is
they basically give Bane the ability to
inject himself with venom whenever he
wants to using electronic devices and so
from here baby basically begins a
campaign of shadowing Batman he quite
literally starts traveling around Gotham
watching Batman at every corner but
because he's so intelligent because of
the fact that he was able to interrogate
other criminals in Gotham in order to
learn more about Batman the result is
that in Bane's mind he's the only worthy
candidate to kill Batman he's the only
worthy Canada to take him out and so
he's part Ally part villain in the sense
that instead of allowing Batman to be
taken out by other criminals Bane
actually starts getting rid of him he
starts killing off the his own
competition thereby setting the stage
for himself and Batman to go against one
another when it comes to the nightfall
story arc itself but a being said that's
effectively the origin of Bane when it
comes to DC we worth at least the orcs
on the using right now remember this is
not set in stone it's entirely possible
that with DC rebirth
you know DC could come out and they
could start releasing a whole bunch of
secret origin stories where they just
basically start retelling the origins of
different characters but until this is
read conned as far as I'm aware this is
the origin that currently exists for his
character but if you guys enjoy this
video and you guys are new here to
comics explain make sure you guys hit
the subscribe button become part of the
Rob core makes you guys drop a like and
leave a comment down below if you guys
have like other ideas for characters
because I'm kind of curious how well
this video we receive it if you guys
have other ideas for characters then
feel free to post them down in the in
the comment section and I will catch you
all in it peace